lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
introducirte a la idea de la notación de
sumas utilizando la letra griega sigma
que será muy pero muy útil en toda tu
carrera de matemático o de físico o
bueno que esté en general relacionado
con las matemáticas así que digamos que
quiero hallar la suma de algunos
términos y estos tienen un patrón entre
ellos digamos a lo mejor que te quiero
calcular la suma de los primeros 10
enteros positivos entonces tengo uno más
dos más tres más cuatro etcétera
todos estos números cuatro cinco seis
siete ocho hasta el nueve más el diez
muy bien entonces ya que ya te
imaginarás lo complicado que puede ser a
lo mejor escribir la suma del 1 al 100
por ejemplo tendríamos que poner uno más
déjenme ponerle un poco más abajo 1 más
3 más todos los números hasta que
lleguemos por ejemplo al 99 más 100
entonces puedes darte cuenta que es
bastante a lo mejor engorroso así que
los matemáticos dicen bueno vamos a
hacer una anotación en vez de poner
estos puntos suspensivos de hacer todo
un renglón de suma mejor vamos a hacer
una anotación que simplifique todo esto
y cuál es esa notación bueno esta de
aquí arriba será lo vamos a poner con
una letra sigma mayúscula
es de esta forma ok y vamos a ir
corriendo un índice digamos tenemos un
índice que empieza en 1 y termina en 10
muy bien entonces el índice lo que nos
va a decir es cómo vamos va cambiando el
número entonces vamos a sumar el índice
qué es lo que quiere decir esto cómo
funciona esencialmente dice bueno
toma tu índice jack y pon primero que
vale 1 entonces cuando vale 1 tenemos
este y vamos a sumar ahora el índice
cuando vale 2 que es éste luego
cambiamos el índice hasta que vale 3 y
ahora sumamos lo que dice aquí cuando el
índice straits que es 3 verdad y así nos
seguimos hasta que el índice llegue a 10
muy bien entonces yo te invito a que
hagas una pausa y te preguntes cómo
funcionaría esta anotación de sigma para
cuando tenemos la suma desde el 1 al 100
bueno yo voy a suponer que ya hiciste
una pausa y que de hecho la respuesta es
la siguiente vamos a tener la suma está
sigma va a ser la suma y nuestro índice
va a empezar en 1 y va a terminar en 100
verdad que es lo que voy a sumar pues
justamente el índice muy bien entonces
no sé vamos a hacer otro ejemplo digamos
que tengo la suma
tengo la suma la suma de pi pi pi vamos
a ponerlo con otro color y por iu
cuadrada muy bien y por y cuadrada y
digamos que empezamos desde cero y hasta
50 entonces otra vez te invito a que
hagas una pausa y más o menos te des
idea de qué significaría esto
entonces si ya hiciste la pausa vamos a
hacerlo esto nos debe quedar que pasa
cuando y vale 0 entonces tengo pi por 0
al cuadrado verdad y por 0 al cuadrado
más ahora que pasa cuando y vale 1 tengo
pi pi por 1 al cuadrado muy bien y
siempre debo en cada paso preguntarme ok
ya llegué al extremo máximo que en este
caso es 50 no entonces como no he
llegado sumó nuevamente verdad y por
ahora y vale 2 por 2 al cuadrado y me
preguntó ya llegué a 50 no entonces sigo
con los siguientes términos y digamos
que eventualmente ya llegamos hasta el
49 cuando iba de 49 y esto da pi por 49
al cuadrado
ahora y vale 50 y entonces tenemos pi
por y al cuadrado que es 50 al cuadrado
entonces como ya llegamos ahí igual a 50
aquí es en donde tenemos nuestra suma
verdad ya llegamos a 50 entonces como
puedes ver esta anotación sigma esta
anotación sigma es muchísimo más limpia
y muy clara para representar la suma
entera de todos estos este de todos
estos términos pero verás que mucha
gente alameda ahora intercambia entre
las dos formas entre la sigma y la de
los puntos suspensivos pero siempre va
en función de lo que estemos trabajando